[Music]
oh you're my kilt bar my kills burma
yummy yummy superstar my kilt bar my
guilt but i love your swivels
strange little dancing fella it's not
kill par it's built bar and they're
delicious
i'm not a strong reader
i've been drunk since i was in the womb
and my father was a religious man
he used to beat me within an inch of my
life
every sunday
neat well anyway i just wanted you to
know the name of that delicious protein
bar you're eating
see ya
[Music]
maybe there's a way to do both
now my build bars got to guilty look so
darn good better than i ever knew it
could
just because you're built
don't mean you can't wear a kilt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
oh that's perfect
room temperature tea when you're when i
have the hive
this is actually this is the perfect
this is perfect body temperature so i
could like put it in a pouch and beat a
drug test well there you go you know i
could i could win a medal for russia at
the olympics you sound different yeah i
do yeah i'm sick so apologies for the
lateness but uh it's a sinus infection
deal and of course it happens when i run
out of the ex clear stuff it's just i
was traveling you know all the stuff
surrounded by people i know it's on the
way uh glad to be with you glad to be
with you it has been a busy week a
little bit i appreciate you guys filling
in for me yesterday yeah absolutely and
sometimes i hate being me because i
should be home in bed right now you
should you'll go there right after is it
you know what i'm gonna ask you you can
comment below because sometimes
sometimes the ladies
and you know i like the ladies
i like a lady a lot
uh
sometimes a lower voice you know some
people think it's got a little bit of a
little deeper yeah
yeah a little ooh yeah the base little
ooh
did you take what the russian skaters
took is that why your voice is lower so
you can go win some medals the point is
they use steroids and they cheat at
everything also i hate the communist
chinese party so uh we have a lot to get
you by the way it's a live show monday
through thursday in case you guys miss
us ever here on youtube i know this week
was an exception because i just fell
down notified yeah yeah we notified i
mean i got really sick it was like greg
louganis ah and
so there was nothing we could do about
it and then it was also day i had to do
work with the half fashion larry but
most 10
a.m eastern you can watch on rumble you
can watch on mug club there's an entire
full hour of the show on mug club today
we're doing the super bowl stephen no
sports taking your chats
and by the way you know i was when i was
watching uh you guys you know watch on
the blaze that's mug club yeah um it's
way better yeah it really is way better
to watch there because you don't have to
you know switch over like from youtube
and stuff like that and
they've improved the user face so
question of the day
should prime minister justin trudeau
have to take a dna test to prove that he
is not because i'm assuming he is the
illegitimate child of fidel
castro i think just make his black face
brown face yes yes exactly put on one of
those little combat hats yeah here's
kiwi brown please put that on yeah so
comment below if you think you should
have to take a dna test in order to be
considered still the legitimate prime
minister of canada also look this is the
biggest we're going to be talking about
this today this is the biggest um really
sort of mass civil rights protest that's
happened in north america in our
lifetime as far as significance
you know it's not burning down a
walgreens it's not just going out and
putting on vagina hats at the state
capitol this is something that is
actually affecting
both canada and the united states and
this is a perfect example of people
saying no more and standing up in a
tangible way and the reason that they
are being squeezed the reason that the
government is acting tyrannical at this
point we'll get into it it is absolutely
terrifying it's because they don't want
this kind of civil protest to happen in
the united states it's an effective
non-violent protest and they are
concerned that it will spread stateside
that's why it's being shut down
so all americans out there you need to
look to your canadian brethren and see
what's happening there and also see the
support that they're getting from the
american government it's just
unbelievable but before we get to that
uh gerald how are you i am better than
you
yep so i would ask how you're doing but
i know full well well i have to save my
words because it's like yeah it's like
i'm it's like i i was necking with
hellraiser
how bad my throat is right now and i had
the kovid i remember i had the covet
like
four weeks ago five weeks ago this is
worse right oh it's so much worse that's
how you knew it was a day and a half and
they said you have a fever i said you're
bullshitting and that was about it
[Laughter]
turns out there are still other things
going around this is way worse and then
of course with shutting a country down
for two years let's do that change and
invoking an emergency uh emergency
powers act to ban
funding and freeze bank accounts well
yes and eliminate voices of dissent so
uh you also you can hear him you know
him you love him and i will be uh on
tour with him there are still tickets
left for pikes peak colorado june 18th
i believe evansville and michigan are
are sold out sorry we even added shows
uh but pikes peak colorado dave landau
how are you sir ahoy and yourself good
yeah
i just realized i answered that in all
the wrong way
like sandwich hat yes yes i've had a
stroke did nothing talking like
president joe biden yeah your ears
bleeding which by the way i'm gonna
we'll talk about about your bit about
joe biden crapping himself at the
vatican oh thank you pretty good oh my
gosh yeah um we so we taped dave's
special on uh on saturday night and uh i
couldn't hear him stage said because the
audience was just it was a majestic
theater was so loud so we had to go into
the green room and listen to the speaker
and me my dad and johnny were just in
tears at some because i hadn't heard
that that must be relatively new yeah
yeah it was well it was as new as him
[ __ ] his pants
we had to wait for the act to happen you
know and then talk about it so uh we'll
see what happens when that special will
be available where we'll make it
available you know because we don't want
to be shut down by the uh the nbc uh
check homes uh but
we honor our african-american brethren
first because it is as you know black
history month
[Music]
here at leadership we want to educate
you
yeah in 2001 viacom acquired b-e-t
which made b-e-t co-founder robert
johnson the first black american
billionaire really yeah some black facts
do you have the second one here uh there
uh dave uh in 2019 magic johnson's
company uh
donated an unprecedented two million
dollars to hbcu grambling state
university wow and it's completely
heterosexual completely 100
uh before phil before filing for
bankruptcy in 2003 rapper master p had
given a recording contract to every
other black person he had ever met in
fact so that's a fact
yeah also like sammy davis junior's like
i'm gonna i'm gonna buy a drink for
everyone at the tropicana babe oh it was
like a whole strip yeah they're like i
don't think you wanted it no no i cannot
cover it like that's going to be 40
million dollars yeah he's like no it's
good bait
mysticals i'm broke that's why when he
was dying there's just the irs showing
up taking rings off his fingers
you're not gonna need this taking out
his glass eye
the hood ornament off of his pontiac
[Laughter]
i could have saved one more with this
pin there's so much going on here in the
country uh i really want to talk about
uh canada in depth because it's gotten
so much worse and if people i know
people have coveted fatigue uh the good
thing is i don't know if he knows masks
you don't need to do anymore in the
vaccine like that's just in time for
election
um
but what's going on in canada i i want
you guys to not just get fatigue and
think okay we've already heard this you
haven't you have not heard what's been
going on it is as someone who was raised
in canada i wanted to publicly renounce
my canadian citizenship apparently you
can't do that really
i don't know why they said you can't i
don't know i mean i can do it
symbolically i renounce i defect
but i guess i still have it it's still
there yeah just sorry can someone cuz
can someone in the control room find out
what that process is yeah just so i can
renounce it and then have the paperwork
you have to call bacon bacon and it's
official right yes exactly that's the
deal yes you have to renounce thinly
sliced ham that's referred to as bacon
yes you have to enjoy worse beer i'm
sorry it's just better beer over there
it is in canada yeah it's like moonshine
come on it's better you're right and i
say that as an alcohol
with somebody with a lot a lot a lot of
experience uh we would have like molson
dry commercials on cartoons and what i
was four years old yeah well i just
thought of watching bugs bunny like
bolson dry st you're like what this
shouldn't be on bugs bunny yeah molson
xxx now back to paw patrol yes
when your dad asked you to run out to
get a beer you know what to grab it
uh all right first though we have to
watch and this is a weird time in our
country because you have tyrannical
governments and i do mean tyrannical
governments
working alongside each other and also
working alongside media we'll get to
what's happening with the the ioc and
nbc and not being able to broadcast any
of their clips on youtube and shutting
down smaller channels and that's also a
concern but you have this happening
across the globe
and then you have protesters young
people this is the first generation of
people
that who are demanding less freedom yeah
it's very weird you know you think of
the civil rights act you think of black
americans they're certainly going like
what are you they're like what do we
want the right to vote and white people
are like that sounds reasonable
or you look at like even you look at the
like the tea party it was a tea party
even the most recent tea party like well
we feel that we're being over taxed and
this is record num record you know
record amount of spending it's like okay
we disagree with you but we understand
now it's like what do you want we want
to take away their rights
okay wait what what
so uh students at the university of reno
nevada
they protested on monday
to bring
masks and mask mandates
back
step back
[Music]
we are here today to organize a protest
to reinstate the mask mandate
this started on thursday after governor
sisalak dropped the mask mandate all
these people now on campus who are not
wearing masks who could possibly be
spreading covet and that is you know
additionally confounded by the fact that
we took away our vaccination requirement
so there's no i have no idea of knowing
how many of my students how many of my
peers how many people walking past me
are unvaccinated and spreading covert at
a much higher rate well all the other
students have a way of knowing who's
who's the [ __ ] please listen to us um
there is a huge
who feels unsafe
please help us it's filled with filthy
casinos
[Applause]
i love how they have on their little
sign solidarity remember we're all in
this together yeah
we want you to force them to wear masks
because we don't feel safe hey what's
what's the uh what's the mortality rate
for someone your age with omicron that's
neither here nor there no no it's both
here and there yeah here's something
here a lot uh before getting a job oh a
reno man yes
well you're hired yeah
yeah that's gonna be a totally worth the
pay yeah paycheck you're giving them
every month they're demanding what are
they demanding mass mandates and vaccine
mandates they're not demanding access to
masks they're not demanding access by
the way if the mask works the way that
you think it works you wear your own
mask
oh that's right ah that's right because
it's only it only works to stop the
spread if someone else is wearing it but
then now they're saying i may not
you're outside marching outdoors and
you're wearing masks are were you were
you concerned about the vlm rides i'm
sure that this grad student was probably
involved in some of those protests as
well mostly peaceful protests yeah and
i'm betting that masks weren't much of a
concern yeah just for crying out loud if
you're talking about you know being
worried that you're outside just with
the black lives matter protests i mean
just look at the smog
well everyone it's it's the same thing
if you just said i think everyone should
wear a birthday party hat right that's
exactly what you're doing right the same
thing someone misreads it they're
wearing the birthday party hat this way
yeah i don't know i thought this is what
we're doing yeah it's about the same
efficacy roughly birthday suit is that
illegal
not if you're at a [ __ ] walk well which
by the way is the greatest reverse
psychology that men ever played on
feminist world they're like god free the
nipple and we're like no
don't do that
hey there's a naked woman walking around
in front of cops i'm going to guard her
with a shield made of a trash can yes
and my phone to record what a useless
world i just think of those students
this is absolute insanity we're all in
this together no we are not we are not
in this together not anymore people are
not in this together when they want you
to be forced to take an mrna injection
in order to conduct commerce in order to
cross state lines yeah that's it's no
longer we're no longer in this together
this is why i don't believe in this
false sense of unity false common ground
there is no common ground with someone
who is protesting to take away your
rights they're demanding fewer rights
this is this is absolute
look it's lazy to say it's absolute
insanity but i don't have another word
for it young people
when you look at at least the hippies
okay they wanted to smoke pot it was
kind of silly but they also didn't like
the war fine at least you understand it
you understand we're saying we shouldn't
be involved in foreign countries we
should be able to put whatever we want
in our bodies okay get it now it's we
should be able to control what you put
on your face and what you put in your
body
freedom
it makes no sense and if you don't want
to go to a school or live in a place
that says you don't you know
free of mask mandates you don't have to
wear a mask
i'm sure you can go online and find a
college that is
equal to the university of reno yes
i know there's somebody watching who
just hates me now i know it's like it's
a good school it's it's not reno grad
forever tattooed on their chest you know
you'd be better off being a phoenix yeah
seriously you might as well what's the
difference yeah just go online just go
on unemployment now and just just cut
through the threads please stop paying
them yes
who's organizing this protest that would
be mr devry he's yeah yeah he's really
pissed he's an adjunct professor
yeah best we've got oh right now yeah
there's just there's a
professor like oh good nobody's here and
shooting heroin yes
now i can go ski that's fantastic who's
who's that brought out there demanding
that everybody else wear a mask and get
an injection she's one of the finest
students we've got
here at university of reno top tier yeah
their rivalry in sports is d force
connected e college right listen they're
fierce opponents steve that's what
happens they just show up like
schenectady reno
okay there's riots after games yes i've
seen it they've yeah they once burnt a
folding chair yeah they did well that
took half the population of their cities
out loud reno the gateway to tahoe as
it's called
uh by the way smash that like button as
you're watching right now before we get
into the stuff that could get us removed
smash the like button right now it helps
with the youtube algorithm and they
don't like it it's a little screw you
don't have to park a truck on the border
you can just smash the like button
speaking of uh of
tyranny and this is so i want to be
clear as to what's going on here because
this is happening to everybody but yeah
we this last week i went into my email
and i got four hard strikes on youtube
which is very rare per copy right
copyright yeah so not like we're gone
and not like we're gone yeah though you
know thank god whoever knows we never
every day is an adventure rumble mug
club we're just we are we are hanging by
a very thin thread um just yesterday
yeah
so we were struck five times and i
thought oh which five videos no it's one
it's one video that was struck
five times by several organizations guys
in the control maybe you guys can get
that to me i know it was nbc the ioc it
was just the ioc the ioc but how does
the ioc strike us four times in one
video five for uh like five different
clips oh okay
it was all from one video right right
but that now here's the thing we don't
want to just it's not just happening to
us it's not just because we're
right-wing and it's not just because
this video happened to criticize the
communist government of china and them
cheating in the communist chinese
olympics
but
that's the net effect here's the thing
this is this is the problem with social
media right now and it's this is why we
need to change the laws uh there needs
to be no more safe harbor 230 something
that needs to be re-examined there's the
law that exists and then you have
youtube and facebook and twitter with
their own policies and sometimes it
actually conflicts with the law for
example single party consent is what
allows for investigative journalism that
means that both parties do not need to
know if a camera is running that's how
you do undercover journalism and then
youtube says no no we're gonna we're
going to get rid of videos that james
o'keefe used even though it's in
accordance with the law we don't want to
have it on our platform well hold on a
second you're supposed to obey the law
the same thing happens here where
there's fair use law just to be clear
you're allowed to use clips certainly
you're allowed to use uh you're allowed
to use video if you're referencing it we
were referencing in this video the
chinese skaters cheating we were
referencing in this video a clip of a ch
of a journalist being ushered away by a
chinese thug a communist chinese thug
and they say well oh hold on a second
this is just because it's the olympics
so uh you can't run it but we can run it
if it's the super bowl again if you're
addressing it the whole principle
the spirit of the law to be clear is you
shouldn't just be able to upload an
entire olympic event make money off of
it right we're not making money anyways
so that component is that component is
gone
second
the spirit of the law is very different
from the letter you're allowed to take a
clip and say look someone cheated at the
olympics and cover it or say look
they're shutting down journalism at the
communist chinese olympics and cover it
you're allowed to say look they're doing
the slalom right next to a nuclear
reactor it looks like the introduction
of the simpsons and you should be
allowed to cover it what this does when
youtube works effectively with
international governing bodies and
governments it allows the big guy namely
nbc who runs the olympics to shut down
the little guy this hurts independent
journalists this throttles the ability
to
to to deliver information which is what
we all thought the internet would be
great for remember it was like there
won't be gatekeepers well now there are
gatekeepers right it's the it used to be
the fcc when you're dealing with radio
or television now it's the ioc and nbc
and vox universal if they have something
that they don't like and they shut it
down so if you want to watch the video
you have to go to mug club or rumble to
see it yeah and it's totally within the
realm of fair use law right and we could
use that for the super bowl like you
said or something like the world cup
that's an international event that's
incredibly popular around the world but
the ioc is basically making their own
rules here and i don't know how they can
get away with that because covering
somebody doing something on the ice and
saying hey that wasn't that wasn't
actually a penalty it's really hard to
do that with still photography right
which is all they pretty much allow or
or you have to go so far as to change
all the like color scheme in the
background and like superimpose yourself
over it to the point where it becomes
comical and then we even saw some of
those videos get struck on other
channels like okay this just makes it
tour you can't criticize any host
country ever for the ioc right or for
the yeah the ioc more like the pos yeah
race
right we raised right now especially
that was what mitt romney put on his
resume he was like i was an ambassador
at the ioc it's like oh so you want to
make me like you less oh yeah it's hard
i know that was possible you put that
right on your resume next to university
of reno there's a linkedin
i went to university of reno and then i
was an ambassador to the ioc i just hit
like was there a nuke button that i'm
gonna hit reno man at least a chemical
bomb it's just this is what happens is
do you think you're more free do you
think the world is a better place right
now no when rules are being applied
selectively that favor of course
communist corporate overlords and of
course we know this with the nba we know
the dollars coming in from china we know
youtube we know fate we know that they
want to get into these markets and they
have to play ball with them
americans certainly not just this show
but liberal shows any show should be
able to cover what is happening
internationally especially when it's
actually in accordance with the law
these companies are acting outside of
the law and it makes you less free
that's it
all right
um you can upload a clip of fox news and
suit digger girls the world supremacist
doesn't get removed no not at all you
upload a clip of saying like hey look
that uh chinese speed skater is cheating
look you can see it right on camera like
well you can't show that no well do you
see what twitter did with define l's
no that account so basically the account
oh yeah those finales all they do yeah
all they do is screenshot like a tweet
from you earlier and then screenshot
something from you more recent that's
hip hypocrisy or whatever about masks or
vaccines okay and retweet what you said
and they were banned last night now i
don't think it's banned forever i think
it's banned for like you know seven days
or whatever right suspended yeah
suspended why am i suspended well you
retweeted uh hate speech was he
suspended no no of course not why
because we don't follow the law but do
you see how that makes like no sense at
all like these tweets are still up from
the original person all i did is put
them side by side so you could see the
hypocrisy and now i'm banned it makes
perfect sense oh it does perfect sense
when you understand
what twitter youtube facebook and nbc
universal look follow the money i don't
know why liberals all of a sudden they
would [ __ ] about citizens united they
would [ __ ] about money in politics when
it comes to the most powerful
corporations that have ever existed
however it's like oh you know what go
make your own uh facebook go make your
own youtube yeah okay but you're
bitching because some guy with some
fracking money is giving money to a pack
do you have any idea how inconsequential
it is compared to the largest companies
that have ever existed
creating rules and bending them so that
the net effect is you can't criticize
the canadian government or china
yeah we're getting to the point though
where we're banning two screenshots and
i'm still trying to defend it though
yeah well we can't just can't allow this
how off the rails are we gonna allow
this to go oh i think we're going a bit
further dave i mean we're not on the
rails at all right yeah we're i mean
well technically we're on the rails like
we were you know like we're an asian who
were pushed by a black man on the subway
in new york yes yeah i guess i'm sorry i
mean white supremacist oh you're right
yes
largest threat yes in the world is white
supremacist domestic terrorists our
apologies for being white you know i
don't even think that
chinese uyghurs have a word for white
supremacists like oh no no no you mean a
government
oh yeah i cancelled showtime yesterday
oh did you i just i realized like i've
never done anything like that where i've
cared enough but i was like i was just
so bothered by that i'm like you know
what i'm just not gonna give money to
this yeah how will i watch the new woke
billions that's what i mean like i can't
damn i can't do it anymore where i'm
like i'm just not gonna pay you to tell
me i'm a piece of [ __ ] well that stings
paul gmat he's like ah dave you hit me
right in my pocketbook
yeah they don't care they don't need me
i'm not drinking merlot
all right michael c hall can afford his
own chemo yes
hey speaking of people who need to
afford some medical treatment so
let it never be said that we have not
been critical of cops yeah on this
program uh cops are not beyond criticism
especially this is a long island man uh
he sued by the when i say long island
man you have a picture in your head it's
not
police for allegedly
ripping off his prosthetic leg during a
wrongful arrest and by allegedly i mean
absolutely here's a clip lucas would not
give his id to police and began
recording on facebook live i wasn't
paying in public security video from the
store shows four stopping police cars
responding at one point he says police
assaulted him while trying to detain him
i have a fractured eye socket lucas says
it got worse according to his attorneys
police ripped off his prosthetic leg so
lucas would fit in the police
to rip that off is like someone ripping
off your skin because it's like
it's almost glued to my skin officers
were seen on video tossing the
prosthetic leg into a police vehicle
well that looks pretty bad
by the way you don't need an al you
don't need an allegory when it's already
bad enough he's like ripping off my
prosthetic leg is almost like ripping
off your prosthetist that's enough right
there you really don't need to go ahead
anymore no there's no worse way to
describe that being run over by a car
and lit on fire is like a thousand
mosquito
it's a bites like losing your leg yeah
it's a lot like having your leg ripped
off and tossed in the back of a paddy
wagon
so i don't have the whole story okay i
want to be clear yeah
though it's hilarious and i mean you
know i feel bad for them but police
charged uh waverly because with
possession of oxyco codone and this is
the problem too where we've just
vilified anyone who takes opioids um
yeah it's terrible there's a chance
there's a chance
he couldn't eat it you know
because he had his leg cut off right
just
going out on the limb well it doesn't
hurt anymore dave it's not there yeah
what i'm talking about how fresh is this
the wood yes exactly
they're looking oh you mean the cut part
oh yeah they're looking at the gangrene
bleeding yeah yeah and then they they
take his pills they're like huh
what's this here sounds like a damn
maraca yeah that's my pain pills because
i'm in really bad pain yeah you see i'm
missing a leg i don't know if you know
but like not only am i missing a leg i
had a fake leg it was there five seconds
ago and now it's not
yeah and that's because of you and it's
it's glued to my skin and now you're
throwing it in the back and matter of
fact can i have those pain pills back ah
let's tell it to a judge
i yeah also i'm a black guy trying to
use a bathroom at a gas station in
suburban new york guess what answer they
gave me
they didn't even give me the key with
that giant wooden paddle and [ __ ] they
just told me to use the bush very much
no and it's hard for me to use the bush
because the ground is uneven and there's
a little known key factor that you seem
to forget that i got a fake leg
which by the way i i'm sorry unspoken
rule i think if any man sees another man
peeing as well as he can in secret
hiding
you leave him alone yeah you leave him
alone
come on just let it go there are people
who've been put on that like sex
offender list because they were peeing
in a bush it's completely unknown guy
code come on come on
go just let it go and if it's a woman
just you don't even bring it up yeah you
don't even bring it up because then at
that point you'll get yeah
you know what and also there's i this is
also the unwritten rule you also extend
it a little bit more for the prosthetic
leg it's what we call the grace leg yes
we do equals you give it a leg up and i
think that's just fair
crying out loud it's true though like
just let them go
be like oh are these oxycontin that's
good i hope you get a refill yeah no we
actually took some from another guy
earlier here some more yeah here's some
have a good day yes i feel like it's
gonna cut to the one-armed bandit from
uh the fugitive and he's like yeah
you're right it really does hurt when
that uh prosthetic gets ripped off yeah
well the irony is that the officer who
arrested him his hand was a hook
i think he'd have some hair
like yeah come on i gotta let you hurt
you know what i'm talking about he said
i don't know
don't bring me into this tommy lee jones
walks up
[Laughter]
i want every prosthetic leg prosthetic
arm fake leg fake arm fake hand
everything i need video of this man pen
right now get it for me yeah now to be
fair i do to be fair to the police um
amputee crime it's a genre and it's on
the rise and um it even it's so common
it even has its own cops spin-off
tonight on dumb cops
that control we're gonna need some
backup
all right now sometimes you got a cuff
of perp to an object okay so they can't
get away you can attend to other
business wait for the cavalry to arrive
all right now this this is an open shut
case right here all right
pain pills
claim to use an amputee all right sure
what do you need pain pills for all
right this is not the first time i've
arrested an amputee
stay tuned for more dumb cops
you know that's actually much more
interesting than normal cops it really
is yeah normal cops say you know by the
end of the run just be like oh tonight
going on in poughkeepsie this man was
going 77 in a 75 zone
what are you doing he's like i'm driving
like all right i'm going to write you a
citation bad boys what you well this is
a show it's just getting out of a ticket
yes steven seagal does a ride along with
cops he goes up to the car it's a hot
blonde he just turns the camera in there
[Laughter]
leans in how you doing
until he sees that she has a fake leg
and he beats her with it yeah
what's pieces of crap she's her adam's
apple and real penis yeah
is that a poodle if i'm arresting
somebody has a fake leg uh come on i'm
just gonna be like this guy's had a bad
day yeah yeah well he's had a bad
while yeah
all right not to say that all people
with one leg have bad days every day no
no they can have great days yeah but
they're just worse than yours yes
lesser than
i'm saying your day's better because you
didn't put on your leg in the morning
right yeah i put you put on your pants
i'm just like you i put on my legs one
at a time and then i don't have to put
on the other leg because it's my body
and then i put on pants one at a time so
i'm just like you that's not at all like
me well you know what when it came out
of my mouth i realized that it didn't
make sense right i did i do i do set my
alarm three minutes earlier as a count
as i have to put a shoe
onto a fake leg and then the fake leg
under my
knee and i have to take into account
which shoe because there's a good chance
that later on i'm gonna be beaten with
it
so i don't wear timberlands no mo now if
you'll excuse me i'm gonna go get some
opium yup runner he beat himself with
his own leg it was very weird
yeah let him go
even if he doesn't need it just let him
go it's been a bad two years what is it
like everyone first person peeing in the
public in suffolk county really oh no he
has a puma imprint on his face oh yeah
he did that himself he's like your honor
come on come on your honor yeah all the
lawyer has to say is yeah uh your honor
he made new york smell like piss
on him right
yeah correlation equals causation so
guilty ah
thank you he's hopping out with the
bailiff
i gotta make that mistake again all
right you know there's people peeing on
the courthouse yes
that's because they're trying to put out
the fire that angela started
like it's a jellyfish
that'll be 25 all right let's also
speaking of walking open wounds so uh uh
i want to well joy reid is going to come
into this segment but monday night a
black lives matter activist quintes
brown he was arrested
for attempting to shoot uh the
louisville mayor uh can't sorry
louisville mayor candidate
you know just watch this clip and then
there's there's more to the back story
that of course shouldn't make sense but
it makes complete sense because it's
2022. just before nine tonight
louisville metro police announced that
they've arrested this man 21-year-old
quintes brown for the shooting at
greenberg's butchertown market office
this morning a police report just
released moments ago says brown was
caught less than a half mile away from
the butchertown market the report says
from police that he had a loaded nine
millimeter magazine in his pants pocket
now investigators have not released a
possible motive in the shooting just yet
earlier today lmpd police chief erica
shields yes they're exploring all
options mr greenberg is
jewish he could have just stopped at
greenberg
political or if it's just are we dealing
with someone
who has mental issues or is venomous i
don't know well i think the person who's
dealing with mental issues is whoever
gave you that flock of seagulls
i don't know what you are edward
scissorhands yeah
robert smith
[Laughter]
we go now to sergeant monday night
why's she so weird you shouldn't be
allowed to be in a position of authority
if you look that weird it's just i know
it's a personal thing but it's just a
general rule when you're talking to the
media and you go yeah so he was jewish
and so there's that
what do you mean so there's that just go
into a like
i guess a barber shop in this case and
go yes i'm a female cop can you make me
look extra dexter lesbian yes
i want people to meet me at first glance
and say
huh
[Laughter]
i don't want to come out on thanksgiving
but i do yes
this saves me an awkward conversation
this helps me i just show up i go dad we
need to talk
i think we understand each other you've
seen eddie in the cruisers yes
[Laughter]
so okay in 2019 brown was actually
recognized by the obama foundation for
his work in the community and he got to
meet
president obama wow what an upstanding
young citizen yeah meanwhile the guy
with the fake leg is getting the crap
kicked out of him by a cop well you know
now he was also on joy reid's show and i
know this is joy reid because she's you
know she changes her she's such a
chameleon it's like joyride never looks
the same twice no no uh 2018 and he told
the mayor to give you know this
organization black lives matter right
this uh what they want and which is kind
of ironic because what this guy want
wanted who just shot the jewish man mr
greenberg i know and great detective
work by the way mr greenberg who is it's
like steven seagal showing up greenberg
he's jewish oh i bet if you check that
bloodline so glad he was here yeah
we wouldn't have known so uh he was
demanding on joy reid from the mayor he
said meet our demands and uh see if he
can catch the irony hint he wanted good
control you're from the home state of
the senate majority leader what do you
want what do you want him to know well i
want you to know that you know we are
here and we won't we want common sense
gun reform and if you're not going to
give us that then we're going to get
everyone out here to vote and we're
going to vote you out of office so if
you want to keep your job yeah then you
know give us what we not what we want
but what we need what humans need we
need common sense gun reform get rid of
those heart rifles
well how about we just get rid of you is
that a good thing we'll get rid of you
because you're using the guns to shoot
people right and i get to keep my gun
what's common sense oh i don't know
shooting jews
yeah it turns out people are still the
problem okay got it you shot at you yeah
i didn't do that [ __ ] with a pistol grip
nope you know
common sense i had a bullet button on
that [ __ ]
i would like to be free to go because
kamala harris just raised uh two million
dollars for me
i'll be right back now keep in mind of
course white supremacy that's the
greatest uh threat to uh to our homeland
security now there was this editorial by
the way suggesting that brown the man
you just saw you just saw both those
videos right i don't need to replay them
everyone saw this yeah yep okay
there was an editorial that was
suggesting he was a republican
after he had already been identified as
a left-wing black class matter activist
let me read this for you it says while
there's been no indication yet that the
activists had ties to any right-wing
organizations and by that i mean yet
they mean there are no ties ever
the shooting comes amid a rise in
threats against politicians fueled by
increasingly violent rhetoric
from extremist republicans
the man you just saw
that guy you mean the guy going for more
gun control yes and is a blm activist
is secretly conservative are you
secretly a white supremacist as well
well that's true he's the black face of
white supremacy
why are you platforming white
supremacists
oh my god where will it end next thing
you're gonna have someone on there with
a fake
mostly leg conservative what are we
talking about here unlike that jewish
man there are no holes in that article
he drinks his cocktail it just
came out
my man of chevits
everywhere
how do you is is the inquirer still
around like there's no fake newspapers
right it's just newspaper right i mean
this is this is this comes from the las
vegas sun well there's been no
indication yet that the activists had
ties to any right-wing organization
stop the story of bat boy was more
credible by far
and these and here's the thing these are
the people who are considered legitimate
news sources like brian step these are
the same people who sign petitions they
want to get rid of joe rogan they want
to get rid of this program because they
want you to have to rely on them you
just saw quintes brown guest on joy read
black lives matter activist here's the
thing either they're lying or they are
so bad at their job
that the net results should be the same
no more las vegas son nope no more reno
grads working at the las vegas no that's
the only place they get hired yes
that's a big step up to go to vegas yeah
they hire exclusively from the
schenectady community college talent
pool
we've had good results we're good about
we feel good about this yeah this is
good they all wear masks here it's great
yeah no one smiles because you can't see
it right uh also because they don't have
teeth so
by the way we just you saw this earlier
today built bars they're a wonderful
sponsor to the show i have lost 35
pounds
yeah bill park has been a big part i
replaced desserts at night with them
they're delicious uh they use real
chocolate go to
built.com use the promo code crowder15
you get 15 off just give them a whirl
they are absolutely delicious no one
needs protein bars you're not you know
no one needs to get but i it just it
tastes like dessert well you freeze it
don't you yeah you can put them in the
freezer and it's almost it tastes like
uh one of those snickers but yeah yeah
that new brownie fudge chunk oh my gosh
i think i have the double chocolate do
you have a double chocolate yeah well
you know i've gained 35 pounds because
of that you're not supposed to eat a box
every day but they're quite tasty yeah
sorry all day every day i mean you eat
some like m m's we keep ordering more
for the studio and i was wondering where
they were going it's not important where
they're going yeah no i think it is dave
i think you're stuck we're abusing the
good graces of sponsors at that point
yeah that's right
the guy's immediately defensive when
you're trying to figure something out
yeah i don't i don't know where they're
going who cares come on guys
next topic i can smell it from your
pores
is that birthday cake do i smell brick
you're sweating mint yes
all right this is the segment that i
really uh want to get to again i was
raised in canada so please don't just go
with me on this because i'm half
canadian
uh i want
you listening watching to understand
really the severity of of the
consequences here there's a reason that
they are trying to shut this down the
trucker protest the trucker freedom
convoy in canada at all levels what do i
mean at all levels i mean the government
trying to shut it down effectively label
these people domestic terrorists the
government's saying that these views are
inadmissible sorry uh impermissible
intolerable then i'm talking about the
government putting leverage and private
organizations to stop funding to these
protests contrast that with kamala
harris and people on the dnc raising
money for terrorist organizations like
black lives matter and for antifa with
these catch and release programs i'm
talking about at every level when they
actually are going to find and imprison
truckers for exercising their freedoms
i'm talking about on every level when
the government is deciding to have
content removed online supporting these
protests and here's the thing
that may not be able to happen in the
united states but guess what
former vice president joe biden made
some calls to canada and was supportive
of it that's when they started enforcing
some of these laws they feel like they
have the full support of the american
government do you think for a second
that if the united states government
president former vice president joe
biden
do you think that if he could do this
here thank god for the constitution the
checks and balances do you think for a
second that he wouldn't
so i want to get to this in canada
because a lot of people don't they are
worried that this could spread to the
united states make no mistake that's
exactly what is going down right now if
this were to happen in the united states
people would realize we don't need to
burn down a walgreens and destroy our
own neighborhoods we can actually
protest especially right now and disrupt
supply chains and make our voices heard
peacefully while still having a net
impact because it's worked in canada
they don't want this to happen in any
state
so before i get to this remember when i
warned you
uh
not too long ago i don't know if we have
a date on it when trudeau was first
starting with and people are saying oh
this is fear-mongering no it's not the
first step towards tyranny is always
othering points of view and especially
if the government decides that certain
points of view are not allowed that's
why the first amendment is so important
the government should never be allowed
to determine what opinions are
permissible and i told you this is the
step toward tyranny when he said it here
you go racists fascists sexist and so
that they hold unacceptable views in
case you've forgotten here he is
small fringe minority
of people who are on their way to ottawa
or who are
holding unacceptable
views that they're expressing done
tyrant
do not represent
the views of canadians don't even want
to hear the rest
unacceptable views done tyrant period
that's it you've crossed the line
that's it
no leader of an allegedly free country
gets to determine what is an
unacceptable view outside of actual
violent crime of course i need to say
that done that's it you're a tyrant he
needs to be out
no i don't want to say i told you so
uh monday justin trudeau again you guys
know about the freedom convoy it's been
entirely peaceful uh invoked canada's
emergencies act yeah
basically putting canada under selective
martial law after discussing
with cabinet and caucus first time since
that's a consultation
with premiers from all provinces and
territories
after speaking with opposition leaders
the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act
to supplement provincial and territorial
capacity to address the blockades
and occupations
it's an occupation i want to be very
clear
the scope of these measures
will be
time limited
geographically targeted
as well as reasonable
and proportionate
hey time limited
time i feel like someone two weeks to
flatten the typically that's yeah it's
almost like the people who he's
violating uh are upset that they were
lied to about measures being time
limited before hmm
i'm weird well i'm curious i thought
this was a small fringe minority why in
the world would that necessitate
emergency powers that were passed in
1988 and never ever ever invoked before
do you want to be beaten with a fake leg
stop asking those questions sounds
interesting but no
it's fine that it's over 30 years it
makes perfect sense yes yeah and by the
way what does this mean this gives uh uh
prime minister um fidel castro's
illegitimate son the power to freeze
corporate bank accounts and cancel
insurance of any trucks participating in
the protest this can be done without a
court order done and it protects the
banks from retribution so last week
toronto dominion bank froze two personal
uh personal bank accounts that each
received 1.1 million dollars for the
protest now it's not about whether you
live in a free country it's not about
whether you live in a country with laws
it's are the laws applied equally yeah
when they raise money
for black lives matter protesters when
they protect organizations like antifa
when this prime minister kneels with
black lives matter activists
and then freezes money in personal
accounts through emergency powers which
he says will be time limited
you no longer live in a free country
yeah
the 1988 act that he's referencing there
gives the government power to do that
for 30 days that's it right he also has
power to do it by himself without
approval for seven days yeah and then it
goes to you know parliament to get voted
on and if it gets voted then he gets 30.
he's got seven days to do whatever the
hell he wants you remember when former
vice president joe biden extended the
rent moratorium right so people didn't
have to pay he's like oh yeah it'll get
struck down by the supreme court but it
gives us a couple more months i'm like
right that's breaking the law you know
it won't hold up they're effectively
acting like it's the purge yeah but for
seven days yeah we can do whatever we
want we'll squeeze them for seven days
that'll break them yeah and then okay
they won't pass it i'll be fine hey how
about no days how about that make that
your new favorite trudeau no days
so it's not your money how about that
yeah you're not allowed to just steal
from your citizens well that should be
obvious that's what it is right it's
thievery from your citizens yeah it's
theft it's theft and it's thuggery
because how do they take the money how
do they intimidate the banks ultimately
it's the government that has guys with
guns oh and also by the way you have a
country of people who largely don't have
guns so uh trudeau and his deputy prime
minister um they also brought into the
scope is the term that they use of money
laundering and anti-terrorism laws okay
see this is like when they broaden the
scope of terrorism to include not just
white supremacists but to include
conservative churches that have happened
like the southern poverty law center you
look at what they do just let's just
we'll broaden the definition here
well doesn't terrorism have to be
violence with uh you know means to a
political no no no no it's just you know
it could be peaceful uh peaceful uh
truck drivers that do you because you'd
be yeah it's white people
money laundering yeah yeah what money
laundering how does that apply here it
doesn't you mean funding a peaceful
protest which your law doesn't cover by
the way specifically you can't use it to
break up a peaceful protest oh no they
can so they can for seven days well they
can because it's canada oh yeah they
also don't have the the first amendment
i know but they're remember when you all
said jordan peterson a lot of people
said jordan peterson was silly because
he said i'll use the pronouns that my
students prefer but i'm not going to be
compelled compelled by the government to
use language so that's not what the
spill is about no it's look it's no
longer a trojan horse like it's it's a
trojan horse only they're riding on the
horse they're no longer hiding in the
horse they're like hey we're here to
screw you
let us in come on in it looks like a fun
horse so the deputy prime minister
brought in the scope of money laundering
and anti-terrorism laws to target and
this was a workaround because gofundme
booted 10 million dollars right that was
raised for the trucker convoy so they've
used this now to target an alternative
platform
give send go here you go first we are
broadening the scope of canada's
anti-money
laundering and terrorist financing rules
so that they cover crowd funding
platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
these changes cover all forms of
transactions
including digital assets
such as crypto currencies as of today
all crowd funding platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
must register with fintrac
and they must report large and
suspicious transactions
to fintrac by the way you know a lot of
the crypto guys are like shoot
our main selling point was that the
government can control it really by the
way we're taking all your crypto you
can't do that yes we can just gonna say
the same thing
that was exactly but it's encrypted
great well you can encrypt it for us
it was it's only a matter of time before
they're like no no it's ours yeah it's
ours it's the same money it's ours now
did you see what she said she said you
have to report large and suspicious
define large because most of these
people that are logging on and giving
money to these truckers are giving like
25 and 40 and 50 100 dollars
to help them out they're giving 20 who
are they the rockefellers i mean that's
large i could be wrong but i believe
there is actually a section on like irs
sheets where you have to fill out like
how much how many uh the amount of drugs
you've sold and what it was and ah i
could be wrong but i think there
actually is a section
like who's doing that right all right
well i did it well it's here on the form
i gotta fill it out pounds of cocaine i
mean i
what does it count what if i put in baby
powder
calling your cpa
poppy tea count yes ah come on
can i write off my gun that i purchased
for this business well just write down
that you ordered 942 000 poppy seed
bagels that'll be fine
that'll work kroger bag of handguns with
serial numbers
they didn't have skus either it was
weird president's choice k-bars i mean
it misfired is that that doesn't count
right it's not right off so so give send
go and we had obviously one of the
truckers on here because 10 million
dollars was raised on gofundme gofundme
decided they were going to freeze it and
give it to charities which of course is
theft and then when they had enough
backlash i said we'll give people a
refund give sen go raise millions of
dollars this was an independent a more
independent right organization and um it
was hacked
oh and it was replaced with this message
condemning the freedom convoy attention
give sen go grifters and hatreds the
canadian government has informed you
that the money you [ __ ] raise to
fund in insurrection is frozen they also
said you helped fund the january in
sixth insurrection in the united states
oh really
what
we have a delorean
they have a delorean and a passport
they said you helped fund an
insurrection in ottawa in fact you are
committed to funding anything that keeps
the raging fire of misinformation going
until it burns the world's democracies
down and this is it the people who fancy
this is why i never liked when people
talked about anonymous they had their
stupid guy folks mess which by the way
if you actually look at guy folks this
guy wanted basically a religious
oligarchy so it's a stupid example to
use people don't understand what he
wanted they are what they're using their
tactics now
to hack freeze and punish peaceful
protesters who are just demanding that
they not be forced to put something in
their bodies think about that for a
second
what's your demand that we that we not
be proactively forced coerced by the
government to put something in our
bodies in order to make a living for our
families and what happens is these
people claim to be rebels and they claim
to be fighting for freedom why because
they've labeled you misinformation oh if
you label someone misinformation then of
course you're not infringing on their
freedoms you're just infringing on you
know the missing it's just you know it's
a it's just it's what brian teller said
yeah and normally we look at
dictatorships that kind of set the tone
for the despots around the world like oh
he did a gaddafi did it so i can do it
to my citizens that's no no people are
looking to the united states and saying
ah january 6th that was an insurrection
though no one has been charged with
insurrection to my knowledge as of this
date
that's the same thing that's happening
in canada here so they're looking to us
and going that's insurrection you mean
guys parked in your capital and shutting
down traffic that's an insurrection do
we need to change that definition as
well yeah what was what was chaz where
they took over eight so it was yeah it's
a summer of love summer of love music
festival summer i've left how many
people were shot well we lost count
it's unbelievable have you but
patriots is out there now so that's cool
yeah
hatred that'll be the one that goes from
white supremacists that's you know it
was a hatred yeah was that quintez brown
well well don't worry they'll have an
acceptable protest list for us to access
yeah yeah you can protest if it's this
go burn down a cvs and take 999 dollars
from from target do they have wendy's in
canada
uh no but you can burn down a tim
hortons fire and ice yeah yeah yeah
there's a lot of tim hortons yeah yeah
there's plenty of those the principle is
the same just you know wreak havoc
damage stuff and the government will
just look the other way uncle sam's
always saying here i don't know either
uncle leaf whatever it is in canada
so europe and sappy yeah
so according to rebel news the personal
data
leaked during the hack of gibson was
used by the cbc to contact harassed
donors who gave the truckers again
people understand this you don't need to
go to venezuela to see government-funded
broadcasting well you really just need
to go to pbs here but they're not as
powerful in canada cbc the canadian
broadcasting corporation decided they
were going to harass
donors and individuals that's the
government again when the government
funds the media
and the media does their bidding you no
longer have a free press when people
[ __ ] about the corporate press in the
united states i get it tom's selling tom
selleck reverse mortgages right wilfred
brimley diabetes it's it's annoying but
i will take a couple hover round
commercials if it means that i don't
have to get my news exclusively from the
government now
mm-hmm
so trudeau also mentioned the the order
provides an opportunity to uh screw this
black face that was if you put it in a
writer yeah he's got black face
shoe polish galore for him yeah why is
there not a million dollars in ear marks
for kiwi shoe polish and our new sponsor
kiwi yeah
canada
we love keith so he mentioned that the
order also provides an opportunity to
compel this is the word that he used
opportunity to compel which if your
testicles have not retracted back into
your body cavity out of fear yet
then i will show you a clip
this means of course they get to force
companies to comply there will be an
ability to compel
prick for just compensation
tow truck owners and operators to
actually do the jobs for which they have
contracts with various orders of
government what happened to collective
bargaining roads clear
this is an example of a specific tool
that is now available
to local police of jurisdiction in
places all across the country if needed
it would be to them to determine whether
or not that is needed hey guys in the
control room too can you give me that
quote that i had from the fortune
article i want to bring that up so this
is uh before we get to that let me give
you the definition
the definition from the dictionary of
compel because it sounds like oh you
just compel
okay means to force or drive especially
to a course of action what he is saying
is this will allow the government to
force people to what do what we demand
how's that freedom
how's that freedom because they're not
just talking about forcing you for
example to
not break the law by the way that's not
compelling you to do anything that's
setting a standard where you cannot harm
somebody else compelling you forcing you
meaning forcing you to do something
proactive like i don't know take a
vaccine that's different than saying
don't shoot that guy don't hit that
person yeah we're going to put this in
you
this experimental mrna uh
i hate using the term vaccine injection
injection works i think that's safe uh
we're going to compel you
we're going to for it's not don't hey
don't break the traffic laws right
because that protects other people's
we're going to compel you we're going to
force you what if they refuse to drive
your car for us yeah what if they what
if a tow truck driver is like no i'm not
going to tow the trucks out of here yeah
what then trudeau so uh well there's a
lot we'll get to that doesn't it seem
like a lot of uh i don't know
a lot of hoops to jump through instead
of just saying you know what you're
right it's your choice yes doesn't it
seem like there's a lot going on yeah a
little bit or just
what this just seems like quite a big
deal right they're not asking to enact
primonocta no it's just they're just
saying like hey hey we just look we
think that we think that uh vaccines
people should be able to take them and
you know we shouldn't uh have to
and they're like let's pull out the 88
yes yes it's it's staggering yeah how
far this is going remember this and this
is why you don't call january 6 an
insurrection yeah because guess what
they call an insurrection people linking
arms saying we're just not going to put
that needle in our ass
that's an insurrection now it's an
insurrection now now what's next if
someone if some if a pharmaceutical
company says hey you know what uh it's
uh you should be taking a baby aspirin
every day yeah okay
okay i see it but you know what i don't
want to no no no it's an insurrection if
you don't take your baby aspirin
they have no right to tell you this this
is all these people want they just want
to be able to continue to make a living
without being forced to take something
that now i understand i'm not saying the
vaccine is entirely without its benefits
or merits but it is irrefutable that
there are no long-term studies on the
effects period that's a valid concern
foursome
and you if i read this correctly the
other day you have gretchen whitmer
worried because even with these borders
now shut down it is affecting michigan
and michigan jobs and it's like you're
the reason this happened right what did
you think jumping on this and causing
all this problems what did you think it
was going to do yeah it wasn't going to
come back to bite you in the ass right
where do you think trudeau got the balls
for this he has shown us he has no balls
in the past right he got it from our
actions right at 100 yep yeah governor
whitman right this is now hitting
michiganders in their pocketbook oh boy
like shutting down their business not
shutting down a board not putting a
truck somewhere that makes it
inconvenient where you have to do you
know you have to you have to use ways to
give you the roundabout way because of a
traffic
disruption you actually walked into
businesses and said hey you got a nice
little business here uh don't you yeah i
do not anymore
done and now you're bitching and it's
affecting michiganders pocketbooks again
it's not do you live in a country with
laws are the laws applied equally more
importantly are they applied equally
based on point of view and that's what's
happening and it's again keep in mind
there's been no violence yeah none from
these truckers the quote from fortune
was the protests in canada have been
mostly peaceful but not entirely okay so
hold on a second mostly peaceful but not
entirely so that's important you go oh
okay so what act of violence occurred
right right yeah bear
on monday the royal canadian mounted
police arrested 12 people who were part
of the alberta protest and seized a
cache of ammunition and weapons
including a machete the rcmp said they
believed the group had a willingness to
use force against the police if any
attempts were made to disrupt the
blockade
okay yeah what is tom cruise gonna come
up with future crime and be like i gotta
arrest you yeah this is what the hell
dumbest thing
what's also bizarre is because in canada
if they had guns they would have
mentioned the guns but like ammunition
and a machete yeah what are they gonna
do hot shots to throw the bullets at you
i mean think about that for a second
it's like there was no act of violence
but they had a knife i saw it in their
eyes did they use it yes
so now violence is having a tool to
protect yourself see that problem when
people say well no mass shootings okay
so it's about mass shootings you want
these laws okay well then you go along
with it okay well then i guess we'll
give up some of our second amendment
rights well no no it's not about
machines now it's about stand your
ground it's about castle doctrine you
shouldn't be allowed to defend yourself
and like oh okay i guess now it's about
the it's a crime to own a gun now it's a
crime to own a machete we're going to
consider an act of violence if a cop
finds you with a knife
have you seen hotel rwanda stephen come
on yeah those are machetes he had a
blu-ray of crocodile dundee yes we had
to shoot him yes
well i think we can all agree on that
one dave
totally well part two yeah yeah exactly
by the way we had a copy of robocop 3 we
shot we beat him with his fake leg just
because of his film selection we had to
it's the uh could have been used as
violence sort of the plot actually does
thicken on the defiant l's account uh i
was just past this by broad again i
don't know if we can bring it up if we
have access to it or not but the last
tweet that they had put out was justin
trudeau
and that was the one that got them it
looks like got them suspended unless
they were referencing another one it
says when a government starts trying to
cancel dissent or avoid dissent is when
it's rapidly losing its moral authority
to govern and that was by harper the
former prime minister i think in 2005
and his next one is the ongoing
blockades and occupations are presenting
serious challenges to law enforcement
ability to effectively enforce the law
because of that the federal government
is invoking the emergencies act to
supplement provincial and territorial
capacity also known as becoming a
dictator right so the people are
providing the people are providing
challenges to government oh you mean
what they're supposed to do at least in
the united states yeah that's the design
of the constitution the whole reason for
the constitution here in the united
states look i know people gonna say i'm
gonna sound like one of those
conservative radio hosts and i'm sorry
for a second here but the whole reason
for the constitution is to allow the
people
to present challenges to the government
yeah
because guess what this country this
country became the united states by
people
with muskets maybe some jiren dhoni air
rifles maybe some buckle guns some pitch
forks presenting challenges
to royalty yeah they said we got to make
sure that the citizens can always
present challenges and people say well
then can you make sure that we still own
guns like of course you can still own
guns and a ship's like hey can i have
cannons
oh yeah you can have cannons can you fit
them well you know why they allowed you
to do that because if you don't it just
builds up and ends up being revolution
and that's what the world had been prior
right nobody could bring anything to
government and say hey fix this this is
a problem
governments would just ignore it and
then the people would eventually have to
rise up and you know marie antoinette
you a couple of times right let them eat
shoe polish syrup
is she the one that loved her horse she
i don't know she was a lover of many
horses
she lived a full life
now
he can also by the way under these
emergency uh under these emergency acts
he can bar travel to from specific areas
he can force evacuation of people and
property sorry compel compel hey can we
compel you to stop wearing blackface
every other thursday can we can we
compel you to just stop wearing
blackface every first third and fifth
thursday of the month and by that we do
mean force yes
it's compelling
it's such a fake word that's what i hate
too yeah that's the word what it means
is we will arrest you we will
potentially seize your vehicle we we
will use our guns to make you do what we
want you to do well uh we were we had 10
million dollars for the truckers and
well we're actually going to present our
guys with guns if you let and uh we feel
compelled now to uh uh to not keep it
yeah compel to the to anybody listening
to it sounds like can we interest you
regardless of what the meaning is yeah
right that's why that no it's not like
we're going to incentivize them right
yeah that's what they but that's what
you think what do you mean compel tax
break yeah yeah good
we're going to give tax breaks to
truckers who are cleared out and what do
you mean by that break their windows and
put their children under protected
custody no mafia type stuff we can tell
freeze their accounts and take all their
money yeah
you know like gaudy tactics yeah yeah
yeah that's why you elected me right so
the the punishment for violating the
emergencies act and here's the thing
this is a two-tiered punishment system
so right now this is a new series of
punishments uh a fine not exceeding 500
or imprisonment not exceeding six months
or both for parking your truck or a fine
not exceeding five thousand dollars or
imprisonment not exceeding five years or
both this could mean jail and fines to
people now keep in mind that is
okay that's to peop to the tow truck
drivers who are if they don't enforce
removing these trucks okay the trucks
which and the trucks keep in mind
it's effect it effectively should be a
parking ticket yeah hey you can't park
there well i did
i mean this could be handled with meter
maids well i did so this is punishment
for people private p private citizens
these are tow trucks who are now being
ordered to pull away the other trucks
that have been parked now those initial
trucks right the people who started the
protest the actual convoy they are being
threatened with hundred thousand dollar
fines wow
and uh of course being put in jail
that's incredible
being put in prison for a long term i
don't know exactly what it is i think it
could be indefinitely
that's another term isn't it they can be
compelled to uh you know compelled to
enter that cell and they're compelled to
remain there indefinitely we have uh i
think it's jailed for a year jailed for
a year
for a parking ticket pretty much but the
parking ticket inconvenience is the
government who by the way kind of
inconvenienced the people by not
allowing them to conduct business or
leave their house i don't know i thought
that was decidedly inconvenient yeah
that seems
you're causing traffic steven
right
have you seen the map that's all just
red you cause we caused traffic at a
bridge
you caused traffic at my front door
because i couldn't even go out to pick
up the piling amazon packages because i
had to spray it down and i wasn't
allowed to leave
you caused traffic in people's
households
have you seen the border for the last
two years i mean is this really slowing
it down more than it was already
yeah
it's it's maybe slowing it down six
minutes it's the model of efficiency
normally but now
yeah it's always yeah it's always been
such a breeze to get through the list
and this this is always being done what
is it you know you look at the patriot
united states it's always being done
what under the guise of security they're
saying that these blockades these
insurrections which are not violent by
the way they're threatening our national
security
so we this is why we have to uh enact
these authoritarian policies and this is
by the way hilarious everyone's a
hypocrite of course but it's not that
justin trudeau is a hypocrite it's that
he doesn't believe what he's saying i've
always said this when nancy pelosi
wanted to lock everybody down and then
she was going and putting you know
getting a blowout in her particle vortex
so she could have the uh the sergeant
greenberg haircut
she was being a hypocrite it's that she
wasn't afraid that the virus had a four
percent mortality rate it's that she
obviously wasn't afraid to go out in
public and not wear a mask and do rules
for thee but not for me it's not that
people are hypocrites everyone is a
hypocrite because we are all sinful
people it's our people being
hypocritical because they don't believe
what they're saying and justin trudeau
let me make my case here when he's
talking about it being a threat to
security and that's a problem it's
hilarious considering that he publicly
supported the 2020 india farmer protest
that utilized what what what blockades
i think you have that overlay there oh
my god okay
crap of the indian blockades trudeau
said and he did it in an accident which
was insensitive he said it's very let me
remind you that canada will always be
there to defend the right to peaceful
protest i said well thank you very much
but could you take off the brown shoe
polish when you talk to us
he said no sternly he just showed up to
speak with their ambassadors with a
jewel on his forehead oh this is just
what i do it's my thing huh you're gonna
dance too pandering son
he said we believe in the importance of
dialogue and that's why we have reached
out through multiple means directly to
the indian authorities to highlight our
concerns
but at no point has trudeau even
attempted to have a dialogue
with the truck really just to be clear
nor anyone in politics right
at all he said no dialogue but when it
comes to other places yeah yeah it comes
to other people yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
we think it's important have a dialogue
yeah well they shut up to redress their
grievances with government and he's like
i gotta go to the united states right
now it's really dangerous here yeah i'll
be back yeah and then he was never back
there were just a there was just a
trudeau shaped cloud of where he used to
be yes sorry
there's just a trudeau shaped hole in
the border wall yes sorry
oh my gosh sorry maybe i can convince
you guys whatever
by the way we shouldn't really be all
that surprised considering uh you know
trudeau's past comments about which
which country would you think that
trudeau
most admires outside of canada
does it start with ah
cancun
administration do you most admire at a
controversial fundraiser dubbed ladies
night trudeau said this
admiration i actually have for china
basic dictatorship is allowing them
uh to actually turn their economy around
on a dime
oh really okay so many things wrong with
that first off yes ladies night and him
is hilarious and appropriate second it
was only controversial like at a con it
was controversial because of the stupid
[ __ ] he said it wouldn't be
controversial if you stopped saying
stupid [ __ ]
and then he also same language their
dictatorship is allowing them ah
that's how he sees you he allows you
some views are impermissible
are intolerable
china's great because their dictatorship
is allowing them that's the difference
between the concept of inalienable
rights the government in the united
states does not grant or take away
rights it serves only
to protect them because they're
recognized as birth rights trudeau
doesn't believe that and by the way the
government of canada does not believe
that even conservative canadians
nowhere else in the united states do you
have that and by the way joe biden
kamala harris nancy pelosi they want us
to go the direction of canada they say
it it's not a surprise they praise them
yeah well hey look if you can just kill
people in silence dissidents you'll have
a booming economy it's fantastic because
that's the most important thing is that
the economy is doing well right right
yeah never mind the people you're
throwing into concentration camps
essentially in china right now or the
millions of people that have been
affected by you know being people that
hold unapproved opinions right right or
being able to have a social credit score
and be able to travel outside of the
country or get a car or get a loan or
anything like that i mean none of that's
important why are you describing economy
are you describing canada well that's
what he wants are you describing china
yeah well that's confusing
either way never i think social credit's
the most important kind of credit i
really do i want my country to be an
episode of black mirror exactly
he admires the chinese so much that he
was actually happy to solicit millions
of dollars for them at a 2016 fundraiser
hey why wasn't that [ __ ] frozen
wasn't on gifts and go
ladies night let me read this from you
from the globe prime minister justin
trudeau was the top draw at a 1500
liberal party cash for access fundraiser
at the mansion of a wealthy chinese
canyon business executive in may wealthy
chinese businessman zangbing who with a
partner donated i thought who was part
of his name
with a partner donated one million to
the pierre elliott trudeau foundation
and the university of montreal faculty
of law uh weeks after the fundraiser ah
so think about that for a second
raising money for china and he said he
loves china he does
you're talking about a country that
commits actual genocide
this is the issue right
can this be what can't be frozen because
this is someone who's in power this is
one of the elites this is a person who's
favored but then you the citizens truck
drivers working class canadians this
same guy who raised that money for a
communist dictatorship can tell you uh
you can't park there and by the way
when i say you can't park there i mean
that i'm going to take all of your
assets and put you in prison yeah well
and dave just so you know there was that
he misread the invitation he thought it
was [ __ ] night oh that's true yes he
loves the [ __ ] culture he was the
only one that paid to get in though yes
then they made him pay to get out stupid
yes when he walked out his period had
synced with the rest of the house
what an awful man
i love it he raised ten dollars that
night though so canadian canadian
dollars so not quite six six dollars six
dollars something like that something
like that this man just for crying out
so hey i mean i do minister menses i
have a question i mean i'm sure a lot of
viewers right now like we always we
always talk through these situations and
obviously give you the reason to be
frustrated mads you know whatever it is
pissed off at government like but so
what can americans do to support
canadians in this well i will say this
advise i guess before it was technically
a country the canadians burned down the
white house well that was that listen
when i was raised jerk move i know well
and exactly when i was raised in canada
they bragged about that for a semester
like yeah that's just because you don't
expect your friends to burn down your
stuff okay
that's true it was sneak attack we get
it but i'm just saying
we never paid him back for that let's so
we should just no i'm joking i'm joking
of course you shouldn't burn down no no
no no no no no no they don't have a
white house anyway so that's fine they
don't do you know this that actually
someone tried to assassinate the
canadian prime minister i believe it was
jean crutche at that point person gets
into the prime minister's house
gets into the house that's that gets up
to the bedroom door has like a plastic
knife and fork that he got from tim
hortons and the wife stopped him by
closing the door
that'll happen yeah and then he was like
but then at that point she called
security and he just sat there and
waited for him was it air bud the
assassin
[Laughter]
there's nothing in the rule books that
says golden retrievers can't kill prime
ministers oh my gosh
so what do yeah look this is the thing
is
and i want you to comment below what
your take has been of course from this
and you know what just so show some
support for canadians out there i don't
know where we can actually help raise
money at this point we'll need to get
back yeah yeah get back to you guys
because i don't know what's happening
with give send go but i will say this
first off they do need your moral
support because they have one-tenth of
population of the united states okay and
the prime minister has the moral support
of this government also keep in mind
where you just talked about that you
know the twitter account that had been
removed if justin trudeau i don't think
it's a conspiracy if you see the
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
is able to compel companies like
gofundme we know that they spoke we know
that gofundme said at the behest
effectively of the government and this
is what affected them
shutting down the donations that were
being raised privately for peaceful
protest i don't think it's too much of a
stretch to say they're making a call to
twitter who works with governmental
authorities to say remove that because
it doesn't look good i think we're
beyond the realm of conspiracy here i'm
not saying that i can prove that's
exactly why that twitter account was
removed but there are so many examples
with irrefutable proof of the government
squeezing youtube squeezing facebook
squeezing gofundme squeezing patreon
right this is squeezing the app store
squeezing amazon that i actually think
it would be silly to assume it's
something different if
we now find ourselves in a situation
where any social media account channel
critical of government is removed that
would be the most likely explanation at
this point yeah can we all can we agree
on that yeah yeah absolutely well then
look they can't enforce their rules in
the united states so if i mean if you
live i don't hope i'm not stepping on
any you know laws here from other
countries but like if you live in
michigan or something like that and you
know some of those truckers are coming
over and you have local access to people
just just letting them know that you
support them right if they're around
there like in in your area go do that
that's at the very least that's going to
be like i would love to i would love to
see a freedom trucker convoy here in the
united states yeah absolutely i would
love to see that here in the united
states especially if it's as peaceful as
it was in canada i know
and i would also love to see canadians
seek asylum i mean for chronic a lot if
people can do it in a caravan from
honduras why can't canadians right now
can they seriously can they come to
michigan can they go to michigan and
claim asylum because they're actually if
oppressive government yes exactly asylum
you do not seek asylum just because your
country is
not as good as the united states that's
not asylum but when the government is
freezing your bank accounts and
threatening to jail you for speaking out
against the government or my god jailing
pastors for still preaching when the
government tried to shut them down i
can't think of a more clear-cut example
of a people claiming asylum if the
united states wants to actually care
about immigrants claiming asylum
it would at no point in our life
would that asylum rule because it also
has to be the nearest country yes at no
point in our life would it be more
appropriate than canadians right now
fleeing
canada to the united states we would
have to grant them asylum how about that
can there be a movement to grant
canadians asylum i don't know what we
can do policy wise but i do know that we
have a lot of people right now watching
and listening i would love to see a
freedom convoy here in the united states
that's a peaceful way to have an impact
i would love to see some lawyers help
get some canadians here in the united
states claiming asylum it is entirely
appropriate and i know you guys you
right now watching listening are
probably saying well i can't do that
well if your truck driver you can you
can talk with your friends
maybe you work at a grocery store
and you can start up you know a bagging
com bat freedom bagging convoy i don't
know
i would love to see tow truck drivers
just leave canada yes no tow trucks to
be found sorry we're all out right
that's a good great actually just leaf
there you go do you have it out of the
attic and uh blank diary yeah and by the
way just
just leave you should be able to because
something something open borders oh no
wait that doesn't apply to you and we're
back at the law not applying equally
yeah
and based on a point of view so that's
what i would love to see and i would
love to hear what your solutions are but
people right now if you're watching if
you're listening canada needs your
support not only because these people
are actually putting their bodies and
their livelihoods on the line
when people say hey you have these
people say when the [ __ ] goes down we
have the guns yeah but guess what if you
don't do anything before that you don't
have the communication methods if
they're god forbid they were ever kind
of a civil war it's guns are not the
only part of that equation and there are
a lot of steps i've said this before
we've gotten in trouble for it because
people tried to say that i was trying to
invoke a civil war no i'm saying there
are so many options before any kind of
violence and these canadians have
figured out a really really effective
one
and there are a lot of ways that you can
make your voices heard peacefully but
more effectively than burning down your
own cities like black lives matter did
that's not what we do
right now the country is scared in
canada and by the way the government of
the united states is terrified that it
comes here for what why are they scared
let's distill this let's be reductive
they're scared because people
who are in charge of shipping right who
are largely in charge of the supply
chain have simply said look we're not
going to do it anymore if you're forcing
us to take something we don't want to
take that's all they've done that's all
they've done and the government is so
terrified that it's basically
1984.
and all eyes are on canada right now if
you're not if your eyes aren't you
better put them there because i
guarantee you former vice president
biden's getting briefings every day and
so is president harris they are
terrified of this happening in the
united states don't let the left be
the party of protest and make everybody
think i don't want i don't want future
civilizations to look back and think oh
the united states only allowed protests
when they were violent and harming their
own communities i want them to look back
at this point in time and say okay who
actually
affected real change and sure 2022 is
going to be a massacre for joe biden but
that's not the only thing hey it looks
like there might be a
uh usa convoy organizing
from indio california to washington dc
starting march 4th
okay
there was one that they tried to start
on facebook and it got shut down yeah
yeah yeah so that's another problem yeah
we'll look into it and the problem is
the united states so there need to be
more because in canada basically you
shut down one or two ports and they're
like oh what do we do whereas here
i mean we have a lot more frozen things
travel there's like ah we're shutting
down you can't go to seattle like we'll
just go around portland here we come
portland here we come and then
portland's like hey chess that's not an
occupation so look nothing that matters
though but people that it doesn't matter
actually that people do look back on
this it is freezing cold yeah
it's not just reason they're
seriously it's cold and they're
difficult like they can seriously kill
them that's how cold it is yeah know
about that but they can't have fuel to
make sure that they have heat in there
that's what i mean they can't have fuel
to even heat them and you can't bring it
to them for free it's not just even food
and bank accounts like they can
literally kill them with the temperature
right now when you add insult to injury
that cold stone creamery is just making
a killing they're just doing their ice
cream and going crazy on the pavement
you're like okay like what are you doing
just mixing it basically oh we just have
we don't even have to pay for slabs yeah
they want some maurices in there no i
don't no i don't brag thank
you
so uh smash that like button here we're
about to play uh uh of course uh steven
sports the super bowl edition smash the
like button because youtube does not
want anyone to see this and of course we
won't criticize the olympics anymore
we've learned our lesson um
i don't look i will say this what do you
expect when you're dealing with prime
minister trudeau you know that i can't
stand him him and uh governor whitmer i
believe are evil people but what do you
expect when you're dealing with someone
who is of course the uh fully legitimate
son of fidel castro
i don't know yep now look oh my god
that's a segment for another day uh i
can say that it is 100 confirmed
it was even on we'll find the old mori
video of fidel
you are the father but we'll do that
another day at youtube piss off
you